for most of last year 50 year-old
Michael McDonald spent grueling hours
training for the Ironman Triathlon in
Kona Hawaii
it is a solitary endeavor it's all on
you I'm the only one that crosses the
finish line but I'm also the only one
that might not cross the finish line it
would be his first Ironman a race that
begins with a 2.4 mile swim continues
with a 112 mile bicycle ride and
finishes with a full marathon 26.2 miles
how long have you been thinking about
doing this I've been thinking about
doing it for about 25 years
it started in the darkest days of my
life
this was in Europe 25 years ago
MacDonald was the tour manager for the
Dave Matthews Band a dream job that was
leading him to those dark places where
were you that was that alcoholic cocaine
addict because I was fully functional to
the outside world I was lying to
everyone but did you know something was
wrong yeah I knew that I didn't
recreative
other people want to go to bed yeah
other people know when to shut it down
yeah and I didn't I didn't have an off
switch in the middle of one wasted
weekend MacDonald switched on the TV and
stumbled upon the Ironman competition
the competitors commitment moved him
what did you feel in that moment it was
a watershed moment for you it is now -
deep down MacDonald believed he could do
it but first he had to clean up his act
he reached out to Aerosmith's than
manager I knew that Tim was involved
with getting that band sober and getting
himself sober and so I cold called Tim
Collins I don't remember how I got his
phone number
I got needed help I needed help Collins
connected him to music
years this is my sponsor which got
McDonald into a a and group counseling
they saved my life
in terms they saved my life yeah it's
that simple
yeah McDonald has since built his own
company Mik management which handles
major artists like Maggie Rogers Leon
bridges and Jon batiste last year as he
approached his 50th birthday and 20th
year of sobriety McDonald decided it was
finally time to take on the Ironman were
you worried in any way it would
disappoint you know I started convincing
myself that I might not make it the week
of the race you see they start laying
the buoys for the swim course yeah and
just each day it's just going further
and further out he remembered the
hundreds of contributors who were
backing him and then I started thinking
well they didn't pay me to finish I just
said I was gonna do it then race day
finally came in Kona waking up that
morning and getting in the water wow
there's a powerful little bitter was
were you thinking about 20 years ago 25
yeah everything all of it you may not
know this but I'm a crier and I mean
literally I tears in my goggles
getting into the water so I was like you
know I came out of the water and I knew
uh what did you know I knew I had it in
12 hours and 42 minutes Michael McDonald
completed the 140 mile course
his wife Becky and their daughters were
there to greet him so how was Kona after
all these years of anticipating it it
was everything I dreamed it would be
well kids weddings you know the birth of
children those moments aside it was the
the best day of my life